during this pandemic the impact of
social distancing and stress
has certainly taken a toll on many
people's mental health
a recent gallup poll shows americans
mental health is worse
than at any point in the last two
decades we all get that
psychologist and cbs news contributor
that's lisa damore joins us
with how to better focus on our
well-being and staying positive
in 2021. lisa it's really good to see
you you know
we're talking a lot about polls today
and one of the latest shows that many
americans are just
struggling to survive day-to-day so how
in the world do we concentrate on
self-care when we're just trying to live
you know it is hard and happy new year
to all of you
what we want to do as an important new
year's resolution
is to commit to excellent self-care
and we have to recommit to this and by
excellent self-care we mean
getting a good night's sleep getting
plenty of physical activity
eating well finding happy distractions
and doing this
goes a long way to buffer the stress of
the pandemic
the challenge of course is the pandemic
is going on so long
that we can get kind of lazy about this
you know it's easier to get in bed and
just scroll on your phone
than to have a disciplined routine that
helps you fall asleep quickly at night
but the way i have come to think about
it it's like the pandemic is a really
long
rainstorm and excellent self-care it's
like a rain gear
it helps to protect us from the pandemic
so getting out your umbrella putting on
your raincoat putting on your rain boots
it doesn't stop the rain but it makes
the storm
easier to weather and that's how we want
to think about self-care now
yeah listen it's a new year but this
pandemic is still very much
alive and well so to speak you say that
we should avoid an
all or nothing way of thinking what does
that mean
so when we feel helpless about so many
things in our lives
it's easy to start to feel helpless
about everything to start to feel like
oh if i can't have
this go the way i want it to go it just
can't happen so that's all or nothing
thinking and we want to steer clear of
that
instead what we want to do is to think
about what we can make happen
so we can't celebrate birthdays in the
ways that we like to but we can still
make them a special day
you know we can't see people in the same
ways we want to but we can still stay
meaningfully connected
and it's important for us to acknowledge
what has been disrupted
to let ourselves be sad and frustrated
about that
to do that work of kind of coming to
terms of what we've had to give up and
when we do that work it actually
creates space it sort of sets the stage
for us to be open to what can happen it
lets us be creative
i think the way we should think about it
is it might not be great
but it can be good enough you also say
it's important to accept the reality
that some things are just beyond our
control
how do we do that and why is that so
very important to do
it's hugely important especially in the
pandemic for us to
really take account of what are the
things in our control
maybe at work or at home or in terms of
our own self-care
and what are the things that are beyond
our control you know how long the
pandemic's going to last you know what
the summer's going to look like
and the way we can actually size this up
is to just think about the fact that we
want to preserve our energy
the pandemic is stressful the pandemic
is tiring
we are going to be better off on so many
fronts mental health included
mental health probably especially if we
point our energy at the things where we
really have say where we can really make
a difference
and don't put too much energy into
worrying about or thinking about things
where we really don't have control also
i like the practice of expressing
gratitude i know that that really helps
and makes a difference
i always think it's better to focus on
what you do have rather than what you
don't
can you just give people a sentence on
why we need to do that on a regular
basis
absolutely having a gratitude practice
thinking about what you're grateful for
is one of the simplest and most
effective ways we know
in psychological research to increase
well-being and life satisfaction
it is worth taking to taking the time to
focus on what you've got
all right i wake up every day and say
breathing that's gratitude number one
thank you lisa de moore
happy new year to you anthony thanks
gail and lisa i always feel calmer after
hearing from lisa